the head of an independent panel
investigating the who's response
to the covet 19 pandemic has told dw the
pandemic could have been avoided
had china acted sooner former liberian
president ellen johnson sirleaf
also pulled up the who for not having
labeled the outbreak
a health emergency and a pandemic
earlier than it did
uh if if china had given information
on on some of the early findings
about a breakout if who
had had the effectiveness of
a timely and effective alarm system yes
it could have been avoided i think our
report is very clear
the report here is a preliminary one
that was made public
earlier in the week now sirleaf heads up
the so-called
independent panel for pandemic
preparedness and response
along with former new zealand prime
minister helen clark
china responded to some of the findings
in this report
as the first country to sound the alarm
against the pandemic we took
prompt and decisive measures even though
he had incomplete information at the
time
we should of course strive to do better
i think any country whether it be china
the us the united kingdom or japan
every country should strive to do better
let's get some perspective on this from
dr claire wenham she's an assistant
professor of global health policy
at the london school of economics and
has been following the course of this
pandemic over the last year dr venom
welcome now ellen johnson surlive told
our channel
that if china and the who acted in time
this pandemic could have been avoided
is that a fair assessment you think
i don't think it is i mean i think
there's some things that we know
china could have done quicker so we know
there were some delays in notifying the
world health organization about this
outbreak
and maybe recognizing the severity of
this outbreak in the early stages
but you have to remember that they were
the first country to ever have seen this
they didn't you know it could have been
nothing
they were you know juggling all these
things so whilst they could have acted
sooner china
um we also you know shouldn't
necessarily suggest that any other
country wouldn't have done the same in
their position
the challenge i have is suggesting that
who should have acted sooner i think who
has done everything they could have done
in this outbreak they you know
convened an emergency committee they
declared a public health emergency
within a month of notification
now yes it took two meetings over the
course of a week or two weeks to
to to get this declaration but if you
think about the ebola outbreak for
example that was almost eight months
after the first case that we had the
public health emergency of international
concern declaration
so i think they acted quite quite
quickly and they have been nothing but
consistent
in providing the best evidence and the
best guidance to
countries across the world i think the
reason we're in this
the this situation i don't think it's
necessarily china
and who i think it's that countries
didn't listen to the who right countries
didn't respond quick enough when they
said
this is an emergency prepare countries
were complacent
particularly countries in europe north
america
who had never really experienced a major
pandemic or epidemic before
just sort of waited and didn't really do
anything and the only things they did do
was stopping travel from china which
we've seen
and has been widely shown to
yet be ineffective says that the who's
alert and response system is archaic and
court
needs to be brought into the digital age
now you mentioned the ebola
epidemic i'd imagine that given
an epidemic like the ebola epidemic or
the zika virus
this would already be a done deal
so again that's the part of the report i
don't agree with so much i think the who
system is quite um
you know forward thinking they have the
the go on network which you know
collaborates data reports from across
all sources using you know uh internet
mining
using reports on something called
pro-med mail which is where doctors can
share information with each other
and so actually i don't think again
that's the problem for me the problem
here is in governments responding to
that information when they have it
fundamentally knowing about this virus a
day or two sooner
hasn't wouldn't really change the way
governments then responded
when they had that information so what
is the role that the who is playing over
here if the
if if you are saying that the problem
lies in countries
not acting fast enough what is the role
that the who is playing
so i think the who is caught between a
rock and a hard place
it's an institution which is a member
state institution so it relies on
and you know informs member states but
it's also
you know it should be empowered by
member states at the moment what we're
seeing is member states across the world
departing from who advice charting their
own course
taking national approaches rather than
thinking about the global level
and i think this raises a much more
important question about the role of the
world health organization how do we get
governments to
both give it the political power to be
able to make the
decisions then follow the guidance
and importantly how do we get
governments to pay it so it can you know
pay it properly so it can it can do all
the things that the world expects it to
do
briefly is there a political will you
find to at all reform the who so that
the who has more teeth as you suggest
the who has been in reform for decades
already
the problem is is that the way it will
get reformed is through governments
agreeing to it at the world health
assembly at the world health assembly
it's one state one vote understand
member states then vote it in
the problem is is it's quite hard to
imagine a situation whereby governments
will give greater power
to the world health organization and in
doing so that implies that they are then
going to cede some of their
own national power to be able to make
decisions independently of sovereign
nations
so they really have to recognize the
benefit from a public health perspective
that can come from having one
global actor making the best public
health decisions
but as we know these decisions aren't
just about public health they're also
about the economy
and so that's where it gets difficult
and this is the real problem
dr claire went in from the london school
of economics thank you so much for
joining us